is there a correlation between any of
the characteristics of these uaps UFOs
and some other characteristic for
example let's say that the Tic Tac
shaped ones are more violent or the
pyramidal shaped ones are faster is
there a classification of them and do
they have some other characteristic
associated with them what we tend to see
are the the smaller Vehicles tend to be
uh think of a sports car or your are
your uh saucer shaped Vehicles whereas
the larger Vehicles let's say a school
bus size is that of a of a cylindrical
object or roughly that of a Tic Tac or
even sometimes described as a telephone
pole and then in shape so cylindrical
and then the the tend to be the large
ones where the large ones tend to be uh
not always but almost exclusively either
triangular shape or Boomerang shape